what's up everybody I'm at BuzzFeed
internet live show we sat down with a
bunch of internet celebrities and asked
them as many questions as we could in
three minutes
check it out party of the street by
manic that it's probably some obscure
obscure jazz recording from the sixties
Smarties I didn't eat breakfast no
breakfast but then one bite of a turkey
sausage and I felt guilty good I'm a
vegetarian cats and dogs no choice both
but dogs dogs dogs dogs Turks and Caicos
even though I've never been there Italy
why the Bahamas never been wanna go
Tahoe I go to Maine every year with my
family I love it
about you with two hearts in the
laughing face probably the bamboo emoji
or the red heart emoji I don't know if
I've actually ever used an emoji heart
yellow heart I have freckles on my feet
my hair these days I like that I'm
outgoing I'm very funny I'm pretty happy
with and my proficiency in music I love
by hair my ability to make people smile
my hair
hi my cat my dog yes yes
yes oh yeah my cat have fun
be happy 42 to have fun and to be young
forever I want to fly and I want to be
invisible flying teleporting
teleportation fine fine yes some sort of
undiscovered creature that is kind of
like human yeah yes ghosts are
definitely real ghosts are real work
hard keep going don't give up a hot dog
is a type of sandwich yes no yes no I'm
very tall
I'm really good at knowing how to make
maple syrup from scratch my interest in
golf I can be tricky I would be a dog or
monkey sorry something that flies Sandra
Bullock myself Leonardo DiCaprio but
favorite word is encyclopedia equations
[Music]